In cycle seven, we no longer have any instructions to issue.
So from now we will not be issuing things. Let's see what can we dispatch. Well,
we have an instruction here that is ready and, we have an instruction here.
They are going to different units, so they can actually both dispatch in
the same cycle. [SOUND] So now, both of these instructions have been dispatched.
And we will, broadcast the result, but there is nothing executing currently, so,
so we don't broadcast anything. So we will mark that the, subtract here,
which is this instruction, started executing in cycle seven,
is going to become eligible for, because, adds and subtracts take two cycles.
So in seven and eight, this is ex, going to execute,
is going to try to broadcast in cycle nine. The multiplication here,
which is this instruction, also starts executing in cycle seven,
is going to take ten cycles, so in cycle 17, it's going to try to
broadcast the result. The other instructions are going to wait for these two so
basically. What that means is that, nothing is really going to happen now,
until the cycle in which one of these two tries to broadcast anything because
dispatches are not going to happen because there is nothing that can go.
Issue cannot happen because we are done issuing everything.
So, we can now kind of fast forward in this, I mean cycle pretty much.
Nothing happened except these two are executing. In cycle nine,
what's going to happen is, this instruction's going to try to broadcast. And
because there is nothing else that wants to broadcast in this cycle,
this broadcast will happen. So what's now going to happen is,
this subtract is going to, find a register, that matches it's tag, which is F8,
write the value, to F8 and the value's going to be minus 2.5 minus 7.1.
So it's going to be minus 9.6. We're going to un-rename F8, so
that it now forces future instructions to read from F8. We're going to
find instructions that are waiting for AD1, like here. And put minus 9.6,
instead of the, tag. And then, we are going to, free this reservation station.
Okay and the, the subtract, has been writing the result in nine.